[Music]
so awesome to have you here's the master
of ceremonies tonight why was it so
important for you to lend your precious
time to this well it's obviously for a
great cause and it's also a lot of fun
and Clayton is a great guy and obviously
magic is a great guy so I always hear a
couple years ago and I had a lot of fun
I was out of town last year but now I'm
back I'm like you know I do every other
year it's a biannual event and she part
of the actor just here to support them I
don't I found her in the parking lot if
anyone knows who this child is please
call the authorities we what's your name
James she says her name is James just so
happy to see that your little guys doing
well can you give us just any other
update how does it feel to have him
being so healthy well you know we're
very grateful for everyone's kindness
and he's doing really great and we're
all very happy about that tonight even
more special everything makes tonight
even more special thank you are you the
princess q robot she's more of a
tyrannical leader right yeah
[Music]